the man accused of sawing a hole through
a motel wall and then taking a
babysitter and a young boy hostage
earlier this year has been charged in
connections to two homicide cases from
the spring we are talking about 24 year
old antonio barry edwards arko manna
joins us in studio after talking to the
family of one of those murder victims in
a story you will only see on 8 news now
denise i was there at that standoff
scene involving antonio barry edwards it
happened in late may our i-team is now
learning that earlier that month on may
9 barry edwards is accused of playing a
part in two separate murders one of the
victims families tells me while they're
relieved someone is behind bars there's
still not enough closure
it's a mother's worst nightmare a
cold-blooded killing leaving a family in
pieces metro police say 39-year-old
sandra cruz-lopez was found dead in a
burned car near lake mead in los feliz
in the northeast valley on may 9. the
i-team confirming antonio berry edwards
is a suspect in that case i want justice
for her sandra's mother jacqueline
telling me police told her sandra was
shot in the back several times put in a
stolen car and then set on fire it was a
vicious death the family says the two
did not know each other now all
jacqueline wants is for sandra to be
remembered as a loving mother of seven
she had family she wasn't just a nobody
out there in las vegas she had a good
heart she was a good person records show
barry edwards is also accused of
shooting and killing a man in a separate
incident in north las vegas that same
day barry edwards was charged with those
two counts of open murder while already
in jail for allegedly holding a
babysitter and a four-year-old boy
hostage during a 29-hour standoff with
metro police in late may i was
devastated sandra's aunt is shocked by
all the disturbing details but she's
happy someone is in custody that gives
us some relief we've been
in a nightmare since may but for
jacqueline an arrest is not enough
that's not going to bring my daughter
back i want them held
accountable for everything that they've
done
now in all barry edwards faces more than
three dozen charges in connection with
the two murders the standoff and other
crimes across the las vegas valley live
in the studio tonight orco manna live
local now